thank you
[Music]
guys are gonna love this uh Texas woman
buys a lamp at a Salvation Army like a
little thrift store okay oh turns it on
what do you think happens man money
falls out murder [ __ ] blows up yeah for
sure it blows up there's a note written
on the inside of the lampshade and you
can only see it when the lights on oh
that's pretty cool that's very that's
very cool it is also very close it's not
like a treasure map it starts peeing on
the floor here's what really happens so
she buys this lamp when she turns it on
wait that's a [ __ ] air filter man
hey that's that [ __ ] for coffee man
check it out she turns it on right when
she brings it on plugs it in blood
stains all over it
[ __ ] how do they know that's a blood
stain because she tested it for blood oh
[ __ ] that she just looks like a wine
spill to me you know how blood reacts to
peroxide yeah bubbles up turns pink oh
yeah that's exactly what it did is that
on the outside or on the inside of it
it's uh I'm not sure if it's on the
outside but it's not visible until you
turn that so that might have been like
someone got their heads blown out in a
[ __ ] hotel it's splattered on that
thing and they'll just like let's give
it to the Salvation there was no way to
trace the actual origin of it but when
you know because she went public with
this to try to find out what it could
possibly be and some experts said oh it
was probably an estate sale by a person
who killed himself oh [ __ ] that's crazy
that's [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] up one why
didn't they just throw it away they
didn't know yeah they didn't know until
I turned it on we didn't know they
didn't know the blood was on there yeah
it probably like absorbed into it or
some shade or dried out and then you
can't see it when it's off the Southwest
Salvation Army not turn that [ __ ] off
yeah dude this is how you bring ghosts
home I thrift store a lot I shop a lot
and they do not wash the clothes before
they just grab it and then they put it
back together how much [ __ ] do you think
you're buying over there I don't know
man a good amount of [ __ ] yeah how
[ __ ] gnarly is that [ __ ] though I uh
recently bought an air fryer from
Walmart you better put some peroxide in
there and [ __ ] at Walmart well better
come test that thing I don't know but it
was it was 90 bucks it was on sale and I
plugged it in I turned it on and went
and then the [ __ ] smoke started
coming out and I was like is this a this
is like the movies dude what the [ __ ]
and then I was like oh [ __ ] I better
unplug it because electrical fire and
then that [ __ ] just kept smoking and it
smelled like burnt rubber a brand new
one with a brand new one dude and you
know I don't have the receipt because I
throw that [ __ ] away dude as soon as you
walk out the door and I was like it's so
smart
why and then I'm like okay
at this point do I want to call and like
ask for another one do I want to go
return it like and it's just sitting
there and all I could think about is how
long I gotta wait for customer service
and is it that's all you can think about
that's all I can think about and I'm
like I'll just buy another one dude I
don't know I'm not able I'm just lazy
yeah do you guys ever return [ __ ] if you
haven't ever done that if you have a
credit card if you follow the credit
card
quite frequently actually it depends if
it's Home Depot or Harbor Freight
absolutely because they make it so easy
and Amazon makes it pretty easy are you
gonna skip it yeah if it's easy yeah I'm
just gonna give it to Salvation Army
there you go just make sure you put some
[ __ ] on it before you give it to the
Salvation Army it's brand new dude like
listed on offer up and just have someone
pick it up that's nice too I'll do that
but it's broken hey some people low on
it for parts dude Nikki's such a sweetie
right so she puts we're about to move
like from LA to here and she takes this
like nice dresser that she had that
she's like ah it's not gonna fit with
the way I want to decorate it uh in
Vegas so I'll just give it up on offer
up right so in these latest ladies are
coming to get it I already take huffing
and puff and take this whole [ __ ]
thing outside from upstairs and [ __ ] and
then these ladies are pulling up and
Nikki's like okay now come help me take
it to the car and I'm like no they're
going to come and [ __ ] get it because
they're getting this [ __ ] for [ __ ]
free why am I going to bust my ass to
give them a free thing that they are
coming to get for free yeah
but she's immediately just going like
that's the thing to do we're going to go
I agree with you I don't carry [ __ ] for
chicks either what the [ __ ] you're
talking about oh is chicks ever coming
to get it yeah there's two old ladies
they're [ __ ] 95 years old yeah of
course you don't carry [ __ ] for kids
that's what he used to do yeah but not
anymore wait so they can't trace that
blood back no because
um Salvation Army said that donation was
Anonymous you know you could just go
there and drop [ __ ] off you don't have
to like give but no they can't take the
sample of the blood and like this mother
I'm tripping I'll stop
that's the reasonable thing I was like
maybe that's the dump course they can do
that but if the person whose blood that
belongs to is not in a system of any
type it won't come back as anything can
they just cut out a piece and give it to
23 and me yeah but then they won't
they'll just come back saying they're
[ __ ] I don't know 50 in Swedish or
some [ __ ] like it's not gonna it won't
tell you who they are oh yeah there's 50
Swedish blood the only way you can
identify someone via blood is if they're
already in the system and it's a felony
or something yeah oh yeah yeah but you
know what speaking on your thing you're
gonna love this this is a total Shepherd
thing but there's a video going around
too of a delivery guy who delivered a a
refrigerator or something to a home that
didn't pay for you have to pay extra if
you want them to take it inside the
house right so this guy just leaves it
at the front step or the front of the
house and then these it's like two women
it's two women that are receiving it and
they want them to put it inside but he's
like he didn't pay for that so he's
trying to leave and look what happens
when he tries to leave they jump them
she's laying on the floor look at this
oh he black
for real bro what are they doing they're
blocking him why
what's that thing we don't even have a
dolly
she said we're women we can't lift that
thing we don't even have a dolly but why
didn't you pay for the service
flying underneath the tires of his truck
he's like hey hey [ __ ] just give me
more money and I'll [ __ ] look this
[ __ ] for you thank God there's like
[ __ ] cameras everywhere now dude
that's insane that's [ __ ] home that's
an activist at home
[Laughter]
absolutely God damn how infuriating she
[ __ ]
is that entitlement yeah that's
entitlement what would you do yeah Bart
what would you do he'd put it in Drive
dude and then reverse and then drive in
the reverse they're preventing him from
leaving and she's [ __ ] forcing him to
do something Beyond his job I'd probably
take the refrigerator across the street
yeah yeah make it even further I'll be
Petty as fun exactly put in the driveway
they don't even have a dolly we're women
we can't do it it's like dude that's not
what I hear these days you apparently
can do everything
that's not what I hear
I know I knew a chick who's like who's
like oh well women just get told that
we're not as strong as men so we don't
try to lift as much and I'm like is that
what you think
who said this
you don't know her but I'm like you
really think that can you believe that
no no it's a belief thing you know like
if you're always told that you're just
you can't do something then you know you
just don't have the confidence so you
believe it and then this thing becomes
heavy as [ __ ] you're like oh I can't
help you guys open it up for [ __ ]
insane though that's not nuts it's this
[ __ ] thing that's going around
though they really think that it's like
what the [ __ ] are you up to just pay the
extra fee you know look at that look at
homegrown look at her back I'm just
standing right there
um she's holding the truck like on the
hood and she's laying under the wheel
why do they look like twins and [ __ ]
yeah they're [ __ ] they're married
shout out to the Golden Girls
there's a sketch where it's like if a
woman's not that strong but if they see
a baby in danger they get the [ __ ]
mom strength yeah yeah yeah so if a car
falls on their kid she could have super
strength get a baby and shove it under
underneath
yeah
[Laughter]
look at this [ __ ] right here yeah
I would not [ __ ] believe it by the
way though if I were to stereotype the
lady who's chilling by the wheel who's
saying that that looks like the type of
lady who is [ __ ] lying that's white
picture in my head right picture yeah it
even says
what was the result of this he ran her
over did they ever say I hate when they
don't follow up yeah it's like yeah just
I don't want to just see it let me
[ __ ] know yeah
yeah I don't know maybe he just did it I
don't know that's like I gotta wait I
still would I wouldn't have done it so
um
I'm sorry that is what happened he
dragged her out of the way and then he
left yeah smart because sometimes uh if
you did if they didn't order this be
careful with your words okay
this is safe everybody's butthole just
puckered up ready keep going sometimes
when they don't order the service when
you when you leave would you leave the
Dispatch Center you're not left with you
don't leave with the right tools so he
might not have a dolly he might not have
the straps or whatever so he's like I
can't even move it if I want oh very
reasonable no he doesn't have the right
tools to bandage that woman up
so it's a liability too yeah if they
didn't order it and you do it
or if you like not crocodile yeah crack
a tile that's on you because his job was
just to deliver it right not to install
it first of all why don't you just call
somebody else like a [ __ ] relative or
they only know women oh also they don't
have [ __ ] first of all they don't have
cash
I don't think they can do even that
because it's not contractually covered
you know like you can't just go over
here's a 50. do this for me like it's
not under the company then they're gonna
go oh what the [ __ ] like you broke this
thing they're not gonna cover it we'll
go inside and knock over a graph which
means home girls probably filing a
lawsuit for [ __ ] getting dragged out
right now but think think about how
insane you have to be to just be like
you know what I know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go under the car yes dude like
[ __ ] Occupy Wall Street [ __ ] I
guarantee if they gave him a 50 he would
have done it yeah yeah give me a break
that's all you have to do not after this
though what happened to my mom same
thing happened so you didn't order the
actual delivery to get the refrigerator
inside so she gave him a couple extra
bucks and he did it oh it's all good
nice she laid it in the car after
that's not what I wanted it in the house
there you go